Sin embargo, crecer rodeado de libros
y con gente que hablaba de esos libros,
no fue un aprendizaje sencillo.
A los 18 años, había desarrollado una profunda pasión por los libros.
No era la única pasión que tenía.
Nací en el sur de la India,
pero crecí en Bengala.
Bengala tiene 2 características:
los platos sabrosos
y los dulces.
Así que a medida que crecía,
desarrollaba también una gran pasión por la comida.
Mi juventud transcurrió entre fines de los años 60 y principios de los 70
también tenía otras pasiones,
pero estas dos eran las que me diferenciaban.
(Risas)
Y entonces la vida era buena, excelente.
Todo iba bien
hasta que cumplí 26 años
y vi la película “Cortocircuito”.
¡Oh!, algunos de ustedes la han visto.
Y parece que están haciendo una nueva versión
para el próximo año.
Es la historia de este robot experimental
que se electrocutó y cobró vida.
Y cuando corría, decía: “Aliméntame, aliméntame”.
Y de repente me di cuenta de que para un robot
información y alimento
eran lo mismo.
Se cargaba de energía de alguna forma
y los datos ingresaban de alguna manera.
Y me puse a pensar,
me pregunté cómo sería
si me imaginase a mí mismo
con la energía y la información como dos entradas,
como si la comida y la información tuviesen formas similares.
Empecé a investigar y esto resultó ser un viaje de 25 años
en el que descubrí
que los seres humanos, en tanto primates,
tenemos estómagos mucho más pequeños
de lo que deberíamos, dado nuestro peso corporal,
y cerebros mucho más grandes.
Y a medida que investigaba más,
llegué a un punto en el que descubrí algo
llamado la hipótesis del tejido costoso
que propone que la tasa metabólica de la determinada masa corporal
de un primate es estática.
Lo que cambia es el equilibrio de los tejidos disponibles.
Y dos de los tejidos más costosos del cuerpo humano
son los del sistema nervioso y del digestivo.
Y ocurrió que la persona que había propuesto esta hipótesis,
que al parecer tuvo grandes resultados alrededor de 1995,
era una mujer llamada Leslie Aiello.
El documento sugería que eran intercambiables.
Si alguien quería que su cerebro tuviese mayor tamaño,
tenía que vivir con un tubo digestivo más pequeño.
Me resultó muy provocador
aceptar esta interconexión.
Entonces, vi el cultivo de información como si se tratase de comida;
habíamos sido cazadores-recolectores de información.
Luego nos convertimos en agricultores y cultivamos información.
¿Esto podría explicar lo que estamos viendo
con las batallas de propiedad intelectual hoy en día?
Debido a que estos eran originalmente cazadores- recolectores,
querían ser libres, errar y recoger la información que querían,
y los que cultivaban información
querían cercarla,
crear propiedad, riqueza, estructura y asentamientos.
Así que siempre iba a haber tensión.
Y vi que en los cultivos
había grandes peleas entre los amantes de la comida
entre los agricultores y los cazadores-recolectores.
Y esto está ocurriendo aquí.
Cuando pasé a la preparación, ocurrió lo mismo,
excepto que había 2 escuelas.
Un grupo de personas decía que la información podía extraerse,
extraerse valor, separarlo y servirlo,
mientras que el otro grupo decía que no,
que se podía fermentar.
El valor surge si se tiene
todo junto, consolidado.
Lo mismo ocurre con la información.
Sin embargo, todo se vuelve agradable con el consumo
porque entonces me di cuenta de que
había muchas maneras diferentes de consumo.
Se compra materia prima en la tienda.
¿Ustedes cocinan? ¿Quieren que los sirvan?
¿Van a un restaurante?
Lo mismo ocurre cuando pienso en la información.
Las analogías eran sorprendentes:
la información tiene fecha de caducidad,
pero hay gente que hace mal uso de la información que no estaba fechada correctamente
y eso puede repercutir en el mercado de valores,
en los valores corporativos, etc.
Y en ese momento estaba cautivado.
Y este proceso lleva cerca de 23 años.
Empecé a pensar en mí mismo
a medida que la gente empieza a confundir la realidad y la ficción:
docudramas, documentales falsos, como quieran llamarlo.
¿Llegaremos a un punto
en que la información tenga un porcentaje de realidad?
¿Llegaremos a etiquetar la información de acuerdo a ese porcentaje de realidad?
¿Veremos qué sucede cuando
la fuente de información se apague, como en una hambruna?
Esto me lleva al último elemento.
Clay Shirky dijo una vez que no existe la sobrecarga de información,
solo hay fallas en el filtraje.
Si vemos la información
desde el punto de vista de la comida,
nunca hay problemas de producción, nunca se habla de sobrecarga de alimentos.
Se trata fundamentalmente de un problema de consumo.
Y tenemos que pensar
cómo hacer dietas y ejercitarnos
para tener las facultades para enfrentar la información,
para que el etiquetado se haga de manera responsable.
De hecho, cuando vi “Súper engórdame”, empecé a pensar
¿qué pasaría si alguien
pasase 31 días ininterrumpidos con noticias de la cadena Fox?
(Risas)
¿Habría tiempo para procesar eso?
Así que empezamos a comprender
que podemos tener enfermedades y toxinas y que necesitamos equilibrar nuestra dieta
y una vez que buscamos, a partir de ese momento,
todo lo que he hecho en términos de consumo,
producción y preparación de la información,
todo lo he considerado desde el punto de vista de los alimentos.
Probablemente esto no ha ayudado en nada a mi silueta
porque me gusta practicar en ambos lados.
Pero me gustaría dejarles esta pregunta:
Si consideramos toda la información que consumimos
como si se tratase de alimentos,
¿qué cambiaríamos?
Muchas gracias por su tiempo.
(Aplausos)